>>Rishi Chandra: So to talk a little bit about
how we actually made this all work, I will
pass it over to Vincent who can actually talk
about it.
>>Vincent Dureau: Sure. So the hardware itself
is going to feel very familiar to anybody
here who watches TV. There is going to be
TV sets, Blu-Ray players, and companion set-top
boxes. And they are going to be very easy
to install because they are going to work
with your existing cable or satellite box
no matter who your pay TV operator is.
So what about the spec itself?
There are actually four key components to
the Google TV hardware spec. Number one, Wi-Fi
and Ethernet built in, of course.
Number two, you are going to connect your
existing cable or satellite box to the Google
TV box using a regular HDMI cable.
In addition, the Google TV box comes with
an I/O blaster built in which is what we are
going to use for control.
By the way, in addition to this, we have also
implemented a special IP protocol between
the Google TV boxes and DISH Network set-top
boxes, and that's the configuration we are
using today and it gives us really tight integration
with the pay TV box. In particular, for instance,
that's how I was able to do a one-click recording
schedule.
Number three, plenty of processing power so
that we can browse the entire Web. There is
also going to be a GPU for enhanced 2D and
3D graphics, and a dedicated DSP that can
do video in high def and audio in surround
sound.
And then number four, there is the Google
TV input devices. They are all going to include
a keyboard and a pointing device so we can
actually navigate Web pages.
And our hardware partners have come up with
designs that I think you are going to love.